je me suis intéressé aux
la à l'âge de 7 ans quand je suis allé
pour la première fois en amazonie et à
cet âge là vous savez qu'on aime bien
comme tout enfant et c'est grimper aux
arbres sauter dans un fleuve courir
après une balle
donc moi j'ai fait ça comme tous les
enfants du monde
mais à 13 milles kilomètres d'ici de
dunkerque ou de paris où j'ai grandi
six ans plus tard j'allais à la
rencontre d'un peuple des indiens satéré
mawé qui vivent en amazonie centrale du
brésil et qui sont connus pour avoir
domestiqué et inventer des techniques de
culture de consommation de conservation
de la plante
wallah n'a plus connu internationalement
comme de guarana polignac oubbana
s'organise l'amazone y est loin d'être
un espace vierge sauvage ou un enfer
vert quand on est souvent comme on la
présente souvent c'est une région de 7
millions de kilomètres carrés et donc
plus grande que l'europe de paris à
moscou
elle a abrité énormément de plantes
utiles dans notre consommation
quotidienne
elle a été le centre d'origine de
domestication le cacao le tabac la
feuille de coca
le manioc beaucoup de patates douces
beaucoup de types de piment et des
plantes un peu moins connus comme la
noix d'amazonie ou le guarana et j'en
passe elle a aussi été cette forêt
amazonienne profondément transformé par
les hommes
ces points noirs représentent autant
d'artefacts archéologiques que nous
sommes en train de découvrir en ce
moment même les zones en jaune sont
dites de terre noire de l'indien ce sont
des terre extrêmement fertile qui sont
le résultat de siècle d'action de
l'homme pour enrichir les sols et en
r des terrains fertiles qui permettent
cette diversité biologique et culturelle
en orange vous avez aussi des zones de
géoglyphes ou de monticules c'est à dire
une transformation qui se voit des
paysages des sols et enfin l'amazone y
est la matrice de près de 500 langues
différentes et autant de peuples dont
vous voyez ici les grandes familles
retenez bien ces chiffres là masoni ses
sept millions de kilomètres carrés et
c'était sans doute dix millions
d'habitants
lorsque les conquistadors sont arrivés
là bas il ya maintenant cinq siècles 500
langues et un centre d'origine et c'est
le message ce soir que je passe
l'amazonie notre futur notamment à
travers cette plante que j'aimerais vous
faire découvrir qui a été domestiqué
dans un interview fleuve
le guarana par un peuple qui vivait des
indiens satéré mawé qui vivent encore
aujourd'hui ils étaient 6000
quand je les ai connus quand j'avais 13
ans ils sont aujourd'hui treize mille et
plus organisés que jamais vous avez ici
deux hommes le troisième en partant de
la droite avec un t-shirt blanc au bada
obadia ce gars il ya un leader
traditionnel se terrait mahomet a lancé
le projet warana en 1994 qui vise à les
tno développement intégré du peuple
satéré mawé à travers la vente de leurs
plantes traditionnelles le guarana ce
projet de la commencer avec ma mère qui
à l'époque commencé sa société de
commerce équitable en france guayapi le
quatrième en partant de la gauche de la
droite excusez moi c'est sergio le fils
de mahdia ce qui aujourd'hui est très
impliqué dans le projet le guarana est à
l'origine une liane dans la forêt que
les indiens satéré mawé ont su
domestiquer en arbustes que vous voyez
ici qui donnent des fruits qui
lorsqu'ils sont récoltés donne lieu à
une intense activité sociale dans les
villages
les fruits sont soigneusement
sélectionnés laver dans les eaux pures
des rivières en dira et marao qui sont
dans la terre indigène de ces indiens
les graines ne sont pas cuites elles
sont séchées dans des fours en argile
ainsi qu'avec des fibres végétales
spéciale dite de karaj paie de ses
terres indigènes pendant plusieurs jours
et plusieurs nuits et ensuite les
graines sont pillées avec de l'eau et là
vient le maître boulanger qui est un
métier extrêmement reconnu chez les
indiens satéré mawé qui va rouler cette
pâte en un bâton se bat on va être
ensuite fumer pendant un mois avec des
bois aromatiques de moules aussi dans
les fumoirs et ensuite se bat on va être
rappelé par les femmes lors des
cérémonies politique on doit prendre des
décisions importantes car le wanna dans
la langue des indiens satéré mawé ça
signifie le principe de toute
connaissance
donc on ne peut pas prendre de bonnes
décisions sans bonnes connaissances
donc on va pouvoir le wanna ça c'est
pratique cela se fait depuis la nuit des
temps mais c'est vivant donc l'âge et du
guarana pas exactement préparé par une
femme qui a raté un bâton mais en tout
cas qui a suivi tout le process que je
vous présente je le bois c'est bon et
j'invite quelqu'un du public courageuse
courageux à venir le prendre et à goûter
se voir anna qui va amener les bonnes
paroles et vous inquiétez pas vous
pouvez le partager
merci lorsque vous allez sur le site web
du consortium des producteurs satéré
mawé newscan.com la première phrase que
vous lisez c'est notre lutte consiste à
produire tout est résumé tout le projet
de commerce équitable est résumé dans
cette phrase
aujourd'hui 500 familles de producteurs
sont organisés pour vendre à un prix
cinq à dix fois plus élevé que le prix
du marché dans le cadre du commerce
équitable
mon ami sergio que vous avez vu tout à
l'heure à la réponse d'un journaliste
lui demandant c'est quoi en fait le
commerce équitable lui a répondu la
chose suivante
on croit souvent que c'est une invention
récente
depuis les années 50 60 avec un prêtre
hollandais qui se seraient organisées
avec des paysans mexicains mais en fait
c'est faux le commerce équitable c'était
là à l'origine et c'est le capitalisme
qui a transformé ce commerce équitable
en une exploitation sergio a raison il a
la bonne parole quelques chiffres
85 milliardaire possède autant que la
moitié de l'humanité
3 milliards d'hommes aujourd'hui 10 % de
la population mondiale 700 millions de
personnes possèdent 85 % des richesses
mondiales
aujourd'hui 9 français sur 10 sont
entendu parler du commerce équitable et
quelles grandes multinationales ne parle
pas de commerce équitable de
développement durable et pourtant le
commerce équitable représente 0,3 pour
cent des échanges mondiaux
une goutte d'eau il faut que nous
passions à l'action et ce n'est pas les
possibilités économiques ou commerciales
qui manquent étant donné que je vous
rappellerai que le pib mondial a été
multiplié par cent quarante depuis les
années 1950
d'après l'organisation mondiale du
commerce je vous ai donné tous ces
chiffres et je vous montre cette photo
de producteurs de noix d'amazonie en
train de traverser des cascades à la
force de leurs bras pour aller chercher
ce produit tous les ans il ya 800
millions d'agriculteurs familiaux dans
le monde qui à mon avis beaucoup d'entre
eux gagnent moins de 1 dollar par jour
et c'est là tout le sens du commerce
équitable en tant qu'outil pas un label
ou une finalité qui va nous permettre de
sauver le monde mais un moyen au service
d'une réelle politique qui va faire
changer les choses
ces mêmes producteurs doivent être
respectées il y en a dans le monde
entier et notamment dans la zone
tropicale
là où se concentre l'essentiel de la
diversité linguistique du monde
n'oubliez pas qu'aujourd'hui 6900
langues sont parlées sur terre et
l'essentiel de la diversité biologique
du monde dont la moitié est concentré
dans à peine 3%
en phase terrestre alors quelles
solutions concrètes
en fait elle existe déjà des solutions
un petit peu partout dans le monde des
pratiques vertueuses des alternatives il
y en a et beaucoup il s'agit de les
relier et c'est le sens du réseau terra
madre qui a été fondée en 2004 à
l'initiative de carlo petrini qui est
aussi fondateur de slow food terra madre
est un réseau international présent dans
170 pays
deux communautés de la nourriture de ce
qui met en scène cette nourriture les
chefs cuisiniers des universitaires les
scientifiques et des activistes
alimentaire et vous savez qu'à un
mouvement sans jeunes est un mouvement
sans avenir et c'est pour ça qu'il ya un
mois et demi avec sergio et bien
d'autres nous étions à l'exposition
universelle pour une grande rencontre
terra madre giovanni we feed the planet
nous nourrissons la planète nous avons
réuni 2500 jeunes producteurs activistes
chef cuisinier pour discuter du futur de
l'alimentation lors d'une conférence
pendant ces trois jours de carlo petrini
le fondateur de slow food qui a plutôt
l'âge de mes parents il a dit la chose
suivante je pense que la durabilité
c'est patent des chiffres et des
chiffres dont on nous parle
ça consiste à créer quelque chose qui
peut être repris par d'autres et avec
sergio nous buvions littéralement ses
paroles en buvant un oil and a ça a fait
beaucoup d'écho évidemment pour nous
parce que nous prenons la suite de nos
parents aujourd'hui et le projet world
anna et durable il n'en est qu'à ses
débuts
alors comme il est coutume de faire
quelque chose de participatif
j'aimerais savoir qui consomment
régulièrement des produits du commerce
équitable dans cette salle une minorité
qui consomment régulièrement des
produits biologiques un peu plus un peu
plus que la moitié et qui va adhérer à
une association pour le maintien de
l'agriculture paysanne des amap qui
adhèrent déjà qui va adhérer à
l'association slow food par exemple pour
ralentir
personne qui a envie de changer les
choses
qui a envie de changer les choses vous
savez ce qu'il vous reste à faire
en fait je terminerais là dessus quand
j'étais jeune et que des amis venez chez
moi il était très étonné de pas trouvé
de nutella de coca cola et à force je me
pose vraiment des questions sur la
normalité de ma famille de ce que je
faisais et je me suis rendu compte avec
terra madre qu'en fait on était des
milliers comme ça et je n'ai pas peur de
dire que c'est une forme de résistance
d'avoir grandi comme ça et de vouloir
continuer à grandir comme ça on est des
milliers et peut être des millions on ne
sait pas encore on est comme une grande
famille il s'agit de nous connecter et
nous donner les moyens de vous connecter
et c'est en nous connectant qu'on pourra
devenir une très grande force de
changement et mettre en équilibre
ces trois piliers de la durabilité qui
sont souvent mis en exergue la qualité
sociale de nos villes la qualité
économique sur laquelle nous avons
atteint un niveau assez élevé je pense
et enfin la qualité environnementale de
notre vie en tant qu'humain sur cette
planète
merci